[WHOOSH]
DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge.
And this is Google Root Access.
Today my guest is Ryan
Damico, founder of Crocodoc.
I had Ryan on last week.
And it was such a
great story, I wanted
to continue the story this week.
So welcome Ryan.
RYAN DAMICO: Thanks Don.
DON DODGE: So last
week, we talked
about how you
started the company
and how it pivoted from
a consumer-facing app
to a more business
and enterprise app.
And how you're now selling
to enterprise customers.
So let's talk a little bit
about-- you made the pivot,
you got focused on enterprise.
How did that process
work to scale it up
and to get it to
a good business?
RYAN DAMICO: It's
a good question.
So we were really sucked into
the thermals of the enterprise
market.
It wasn't our idea initially.
We built this technology.
Companies took notice and
started knocking at our door.
So once that happened,
we did our first deal
with Yammer that
went really well.
And they became our
lighthouse customer
that really helped us get
our next set of customers.
And especially when
you're a small start up,
every one of those reference
accounts really matters.
So each company that we were
able to convert into a customer
really snowballed and
made the next one easier
and the next one easier.
Our whole strategy
was-- in starting
at the top of the market and
going after these big companies
first-- was really to
build up reputation.
So when people thought about
high-quality document viewing
in any kind of
professional web app,
they thought about
us immediately.
And eventually that
started to happen for us.
And that was what kind
of led us down and helped
us grow our sales.
DON DODGE: So were
those like OEM kinds
of arrangements where they
were using the Crocodoc product
within their product?
RYAN DAMICO: Yeah.
Yep.
We OEM'd the service.
It was a hosted
web API basically.
And sometimes you would
see the Crocodoc branding.
Sometimes it was a white
label implementation.
But in every case, we
talked about the customer.
We had a good
relationship with them.
And we really just talked
about all the different ways
that our technology
was integrated
into the product
and the benefits
for the users of those products.
And that was a really
good story for us to tell.
DON DODGE: So was
the business model
to be an OEM provider to a
bunch of different products?
Or was that just a early
revenue step on the way
to a bigger vision?
RYAN DAMICO: Yeah that was
a deliberate stepping stone
for us.
What we really wanted to
do with the company is
take documents and really
make them first-class citizens
of the web-- just like
images and videos are
all over the place, they're
really easy to view.
We wanted to see the same shift
happen from documents, where
you didn't need to
download large files
and have the right version of
Microsoft Office installed,
or Acrobat installed
on your desktop.
We wanted to make that
ubiquitous across all devices
everywhere.
So OEMing this
viewer out was kind
of one step in that direction.
But really, the
bigger picture was
to just change the way people
are interacting with content
and just make that a much
easier and better experience
for users.
DON DODGE: So when
I first met you,
you were two or three guys
working on a consumer thing.
Now you're at the
point where you're
OEMing your product to
pretty large companies.
How big are you at that point?
And have you raised
any more money?
RYAN DAMICO: We did raise
around a couple years ago just
to keep things going and give
us a little bit more cash flow
to makes some more hires.
But the business took
off pretty quickly.
I think, in the last two years
Crocodoc has converted over,
I think, 200 million
different documents
from our various customers.
So that ramped up
pretty quickly.
And it's still
growing even faster
as we expand not only
to more customers,
but as existing
customers use us more.
It's really interesting to
see that growth happening.
So yeah, we did raise a
little bit of funding.
But we've been very profitable
for the last couple of years.
DON DODGE: So you're profitable.
Did you hire more people?
RYAN DAMICO: A little bit.
We grew from four founders to a
whopping seven people in total.
DON DODGE: OK.
So seven people.
You've got a good product.
You're selling to
the enterprise.
You're profitable.
Things are going well.
Then you start getting knocks
on the door for acquisitions.
So how did you think about
those early acquisition offers
and whether to
accept them or not?
RYAN DAMICO: We were
really fortunate.
We had a number
of opportunities.
And they dated way back to
when we were just starting out
from the pivot from our
first product WebNotes
into what is now Crocodoc.
And you know, the first
few are really exciting.
You get really into it.
And then you kind of
go through a process
and you realize for whatever
reason it didn't work.
It wasn't good timing,
wasn't good fit, et cetera.
And then you realize that
was a huge waste of time
and a waste of focus.
So after that, we didn't really
want to go through that process
unless we were really
interested in it.
And the funny thing is
that in the early stages
of our start-up-- I
mean, we've been around
for about eight years or
so-- the business plan was
essentially to sell the company.
That was another fallacy.
But then we switched that
mindset at one point to say,
you know what, screw that.
We want to build the best
company we ever worked for.
And then of course, that's
when we started to do well
and got some other interest.
So it was an
interesting process.
But the reason why we
chose to go with Box
was really interesting.
It really jumped out
at us as an opportunity
that I think very few
startups ever get.
Which is to not only join
another company that's
doing really exciting
things, but to be
able to stay true to your
vision as a startup company.
And be, not just a
feature or a product
that gets end-of-lifed at
another company, but actually
to become a core,
strategic element
of the company you're at.
And at Box, we get
to do two things.
We get to continue building this
really great technology that we
set out to build, with the same
vision of making content really
a first-class citizen on the
web, especially for documents.
We get to expand what we're
doing so we're not just
selling a developer
tool anymore.
But we're also developing
an end-user integration.
So when you use Box, you
actually use our stuff.
And these are all the things we
wanted to do as a seven person
company but just never
have the opportunity to,
without losing tons of focus.
So it's been a really
great opportunity
to just be able to just do the
same thing that we were before,
but just to it 10 times better.
DON DODGE: So that's
a great segue-way.
Let's go back to those
earlier acquisition offers.
Was it that the
price wasn't right?
Or the timing wasn't right?
Or the cultural
fit wasn't right?
What kinds of things
did you go through?
Because getting an acquisition
offer's pretty exciting stuff.
RYAN DAMICO: Yeah it is.
And looking back,
it's kind of funny
how your perspective
shifts over time.
But for us, I mean,
we turned down
offers for all those reasons
and more at various points.
But the main thing was timing.
When you're a
startup, you really
are being super
ambitious in going
after a really large vision.
And we especially didn't
want to give up on that
before we knew it
was even possible.
And I think the timing
was great with Box
because we validated the
technology we were building.
We validated the market
need for what we were doing.
And we ourselves were just
entering a big inflection
point.
So it was either-- going to
raise a big round of financing,
go join another
company-- something
big was going to happen.
And it turned out that
the timing and the stars
kind of lined up
at the right point.
So we saw the path
to do what we really
wanted to do and effect
this huge change--
and just have a lot
of fun doing it,
and work with a great company
that was already established.
As a side note, had
we not gone down
the path we did-- where
we were licensing a web
API-- plan B was actually
to compete with Box.
So it's a pretty small
world, and kind of funny
when we look back where
we were at that point.
DON DODGE: So another
aspect of that
decision is, you
have investors who
invested in your company four
years ago or six years ago.
They want an exit.
So it's not just about
you and what you want.
You had to balance the
promises made to investors.
So how did you go
through that decision
and turn down earlier
acquisition offers
and accept this one?
RYAN DAMICO: Yeah
well, it did turn out
that this was a great
outcome for everyone.
That's not always the case.
A lot of companies will
just go lowball startups,
hoping that they just bite.
And maybe sometimes that
makes sense for a startup
if things aren't going well.
But we decided to hang in
there for the longer run.
And I think all of our
investors knew that.
We were never in this
to just kind of flip
the company real quick.
We actually set out
to change something
that touches millions and
millions of people using
all sorts of applications
all over the place.
So lucky for our
investors, we didn't
want to do a lifestyle business.
So that would have been
a little bit difficult.
But we really wanted
to make an impact.
And then it turned
out that the best way
to do that was to have a great
outcome for the investors too.
DON DODGE: So
there was alignment
between the investors
and the acquiring company
and what you wanted to do.
Everything lined up
perfectly, and it
was a-- was it a fairly
obvious decision for you,
or was it still troubling?
RYAN DAMICO: It's hard.
I don't think it's ever easy
to decide to sell your company.
It was pretty difficult for us.
Every time the
conversation would come up,
it just really
forces you to think
about where you're
going, what you're
doing-- I think looking back,
it was just great timing for us.
It was a really good decision.
It was a really great fit.
We're just happy
where we are now.
But it's scary when
you're your own company.
And the concept of
joining another one-- it's
a scary thought.
It really forces you to
think through a lot of things
when you have a
conversation like that.
And also as an
entrepreneur, you learn
that you don't want to go
through a process like that
unless you really think there's
a serious possibility that it's
going to go somewhere.
Because otherwise
you can just spend
a lot of mental and emotional
energy in an unnecessary way.
DON DODGE: Well it's
a great story, Ryan.
And thanks for joining us.
RYAN DAMICO: Thanks so much.
DON DODGE: OK.
And thank you for joining us.
Before I sign off, if you're
a Google Cloud developer,
we have a special offer for you,
a $2,000 credit for Root Access
viewers.
The details are on your screen.
Thank you very much for joining
us and see you next time.